[Music]
is there
life on mars it's something that humans
have pondered for centuries
you're quite convinced as a scientist
that living intelligence as we know it
does not exist on mars
i say the chances against it are a
thousand to one if mars does have life
it will be a life very different from
the sort we have here
as improbable as it may seem science may
soon have an answer
this month spacecrafts from nasa and
china will arrive at the red planet
at one of the most pivotal moments of
space exploration
this is the first time that a nasa
mission will be explicitly looking for
life on mars
since the 1970s viking missions which
were also
the first successful u.s landings on
mars it's just so profoundly exciting to
me
and and to others on our team to be able
to
be directly looking for life on another
planet
it's just a sort of once in a lifetime
opportunity this is an enormous matter
of prestigious i strongly suspect
that senior members of china's political
leadership will be literally in the room
watching as the craft de-orbits
and lands china is tian-won won
entered marja's orbit on february 10th
and is now circling the planet
with an orbiter from the united arab
emirates which had arrived
a day earlier chiang 1 isn't expected to
land on mars until may
while the uae's mission won't land at
all
so now all eyes are on the american
mission
mars 2020 and its nuclear-powered rover
perseverance four engine ignition
two after a months long journey through
deep space
the probe is expected to touch down on
mars jezreel crater on february 18th
ken williford is a nasa astrobiologist
who's been working on the mission since
mars is hard you know landing on mars
especially
is hard it's been called the seven
minutes of terror
nasa's first successful landing was in
1976 with the viking one and two
missions
their search to find evidence of life
was unsuccessful
and so for a generation afterwards
nasa's missions to the red planet
focused on other scientific questions
but with the six wheeled perseverance
rover which is about the size and weight
of an suv
nasa is once again on an interplanetary
safari
to search for ancient life
[Music]
we use our rover as a robotic geologist
almost like a human would we look around
with our eyes first of all we use our
cameras
there's an instrument called super cam
which is sort of like a big cyclops
looking eye up on the remote sensing
mast on top of the rover
which is actually a telescope with a
laser in the middle of it
once the telescope has located an area
of rock to examine
more lasers shoot out from two very
important instruments
to scan the rocks for biosignatures of
ancient life
one is called pixel one is called
sherlock
both of them use a beam and the beam
itself is about the diameter of your
hair
this beam scans an area about the size
of a postage stamp
to create a map of the rock's chemical
composition
pieces of the rock can also be extracted
which will be stored for an ambitious
sample return mission being developed by
nasa with the european space agency
that mission is slated for an early
2030s launch
so why is examining and collecting these
rocks so important
for the vast majority of the history of
earth all life was
microscopic and microbial think about
pond scum at the edge of a lake or a
pond on earth this green
gooey stuff and when you mix that gooey
pond scum
with the sediment on the edge of a lake
or a pond
uh it can form a rock formation that we
call a stromatolite
scientists believe that these wrinkly
rock formations if found on mars
could be evidence of ancient microbial
life formed on mars
had seasoned rivers flowing water some
four billion years ago
also writing with perseverance will be
two audio recorders
that will allow us to hear what mars
sounds like and an oxygen extracting
generator called moxie
the success of moxie will be essential
for supporting human exploration of mars
in the future
but the most eye-catching of
perseverance's new tech is ingenuity
this robotic four-pound helicopter will
be the first aircraft
to attempt controlled flight on another
planet
in may perseverance is expected to be
joined on the martian surface by the
chinese spacecraft
tianuan won or questions to heaven k11
is expected to
come down in the area known as utopia
dean chang is a senior fellow at the
heritage foundation
whose research focuses on china and
space policy
it is enormously daring because this is
china's first
interplanetary probe and they're going
to deploy a rover
if successful this would make china the
only nation other than the us
to deploy a rover on the martian surface
chinese officials have been tight-lipped
about many details of the mission
the chinese don't explicitly say that
tien won one's main mission is to search
for ancient life
like it is for perseverance but this is
a far more complicated moment for
china so managing expectations for its
very first martian landing
might be a more important objective for
china
this is partly science um the chinese
have said that
great powers contribute to the wealth of
human knowledge
but it is also prestige um because this
is being accomplished under xi jinping
it is being accomplished under the
chinese common party
it is a statement of china's ability to
rival other major powers
but china has prepared itself for this
moment with a string of successes in a
short amount of time
in 2003 it became the third nation
to launch an astronaut into orbit in
2019
china deployed a lunar rover on the far
side of the moon
the first and only country to do so and
successfully collected and returned
samples to earth
china said it plans to launch a space
station in 2022
the chinese are are have one of the most
opaque
space programs out there they are
very close-mouthed on basic data such as
for example the overall size of china's
space budget
[Music]
so at least for now the us mars 2020
mission
might be in the best position to find
the answers we've all been waiting for
mars 2020 and mars sample return are
primarily motivated by this
really fundamental uh science question
are we alone in the universe
i think it's very clear that mars could
have supported life
in its distant past but this is the big
question
my guess is that people have been asking
a question like this for as long as
there
have been people